-Let's get to the news.
President Trump today tweeted,
"Big rally tonight
in Cincinnati, Ohio.
See you there.
P.S. --
Our country is doing great."
[ Light laughter ]
That's a weird thing
to put in a P.S.
[ Laughter ]
That's like if you've got a text
from your husband that said,
"Working late tonight.
P.S. -- Definitely
not cheating on you."
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of
President Trump's rally tonight,
Republicans said
they were unsure
of how President Trump
would respond
to potential racist chants
though, if I had to guess,
I'd say
with a conductor's baton?
[ Laughter ]
"Let's hear you in the back.
President Trump spoke yesterda
with the Russian President
Vladimir Putin
to offer assistance
to combat ongoing
Siberian wildfires.
Said Putin, "Yes, Donald,
we've tried water."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, good, good, yeah.
You want to --
You want to start with that,
definitely."
[ Laughter ]
According to
"The New York Times,"
only seven candidates
have qualified
for the next Democratic debate
and one has qualified
for the Galactic High Council.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
According to a new report,
scientists are able
to convert human brain signals
into basic spoken words
and phrases,
though they're still working out
some of the kinks.
Check it out.
-Go to Joe 30330.
[ Laughter ]
-Getting there.
It's getting there.
[ Applause ]
It's almost there.
According to a new report,
more than 900
New York City classrooms
tested positive
for having exposed lead paint.
"Duh, that's what makes
the lockers taste so good,
said a guy from Queens.
[ Laughter ]
Five Ohio police officers
are facing possible discipline
over the improper arrest
of adult film star
Stormy Daniels in 2018.
"Possible Discipline" --
wasn't she in that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Stammers ]
I was told!
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to
"The New York Times,"
registered sex offender
Jeffrey Epstein
has expressed interest
in cryogenically freezing
his head and penis.
"Penis was also an option?!"
yelled Walt Disney.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Mm.
[ Applause ]
-Whoo!
-My luck was bound to run ou
with that joke.
[ Laughter ]
Officials in New York
are struggling to catch
a herd of 75 escaped buffalo
that have split up
into smaller groups.
The groups are the jocks,
the nerds, the band geeks,
the theater dorks,
and the plastics.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally...
[ Applause continues ]
...according to a new study,
customers rated Taco Bell
as the worst
Mexican fast-food chain.
Said Taco Bell, "Guys, guys!
They called us food!"
[ Laughter ]